sarkozy comme
kadhafi je suis enchanté de vous parler
je n'ai pas oublié notre rencontre je
garde un excellent souvenir de la
qualité de vos analyses méritait
amplement votre titre de guide un hymne
au minimum entend dire vous conduire
leur paraissent comme en asie médicaux
aux larmes et le titre d'hôtel oui
monsieur le type j'espère recevoir en
france où me rendre libye une charge
marshall je compte sur votre prière
monsieur liquide je ne prie pas de la
même manière que vous mais je prie le
même dieu que vous choquera dessous que
je vous exprime mes respects et mon
amitié monsieur liquide
[Applaudissements]
le 28 mai 2007 l'un des tout premiers
dirigeants du monde à qui le président
français tout juste élu téléphonez
longuement était le chef d'un petit pays
d'afrique du nord
[Musique]
dès le début donc au dessus de lui
planait l'ombre du dictateur
bientôt celui ci viendra le visiter en
ces lieux il obtiendra jusqu'aux
derniers instants de son mandat et
continuera de le hanter après
jamais sous la vème république un
dictateur n'avait ainsi marqué de son
empreinte le quinquennat d'un président
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toute cette histoire a commencé deux ans
avant que le futur président on entre à
l'elysée lorsqu'il est allé faire la
connaissance du dictateur un jour
d'octobre 2005
il est alors un fringant ministre de
l'intérieur de jacques chirac qui ne
fait pas mystère de ses ambitions
présidentielles
depuis l'aéroport sans qu'on voie file à
travers tripoli capitale d'un état de
six millions d'habitants que la manne
pétrolière a rendu le plus riche
d'afrique
[Musique]
que
sur les murs s'affiche partout l'homme
qui le dirige d'une main de fer depuis
[Musique]
officiellement le ministre a été conviée
ici à venir s'entretenir de la lutte
antiterroriste et de l'immigration
irrégulière
pourquoi voulez vous vouliez vous allez
en hôtel
[Musique]
en coulisses toutefois cette visite a
pour le ministre d'autres enjeux plus
personnel elle a été initiée par un
homme de l'ombre un libanais un
intermédiaire en armement à la fois
proche de plusieurs membres de son
entourage est familier du pouvoir libyen
en 2005
je rencontre le fils du colonel kadhafi
en visite privée en france alors ils
m'invitent en libye ou à les rencontrer
son père le colonel kadhafi et je
rencontre kadhafi quand je parlais de
nicolas sarkozy lui je parlait de lui
comme quelqu'un qui allait changer
beaucoup
la démarche française en général dans le
domaine de la politique extérieure c'est
celle qui s'est emballé sur sarkozy seif
qu'un projet son père papa papa papa
papa pas par les formes qui n'est pas
papa formidable
je retourne en france je vois monsieur
beer et des choses sont mises en place
et monsieur client était venu préparer
la visite plusieurs fois
deux fois pas forcément une fois
monsieur claude guéant avait ses propres
contacts
signe de l'importance qu'il accorde à
cette relation son plus proche
collaborateur devient dès lors son agent
de liaison avec les libyens
[Musique]
en fin de matinée devant la tente
bédouine plantée au milieu de son palais
caserne apparaît le dictateur
[Musique]
depuis peu il n'est plus un chef d'état
paria à la tête d'un pays sous embargo
en renonçant au terrorisme et à l'arme
nucléaire il est devenu fréquentable aux
yeux des occidentaux
sous 70 il a déjà reçu des dirigeants
européens
mais ce jour-là il surprend ceux qui
connaissent les habitudes comme
l'ambassadeur français en poste à
tripoli depuis quatre ans
colonel kadhafi ne recevait jamais le
matin parce qu'ils avaient des nuits
sans doute très longue et le matin il
était toujours un peu dans un temps
brouillard se dire et donc c'était
plutôt le soir l'après midi ou plutôt le
soir l'avait reçue tout de suite la
diplomate aura mansour est une intime du
dictateur la responsable de ces fameuses
amazones fagalde yannig al jazeera le
guide m'a dit zohra vous n'auront
quelqu'un qui sera candidat à des
élections importantes s'il arrivait au
pouvoir
nous pourrions entretenir de bonnes
relations avec son pays ça vaut le coup
non fallait bien cela ils l'ont dit
l'était c'était l'objectif principal
on accueille ce sarkozy parce qu'on sait
qu'il a il peut avoir un destin
important en france être le futur
président
enfin l'ambitieux ministre nos vies sur
la scène internationale et
l'indéboulonnable dictateur au pouvoir
depuis trente six ans font connaissance
l'empressement du libyen rencontre est
ce possible président français a une
raison
après avoir vainement tenté de prendre
la tête du monde arabe le dictateur rêve
de fonder des états unis d'afrique
que bien sûr il dirigerait
[Musique]
autoproclamé roi des rois ces milliards
lui donne les moyens de ses ambitions
mais sur sa route il craint la france et
sa très actif politique africaine la
france qui s'est toujours opposé à ces
projets
ainsi ses rapports avec le président
chirac sentiers notoirement glaciaux
il fallait donc améliorer nos relations
avec la france coûte que coûte qu'elle
ne perturbe pas par son influence sur
certains pays africains les discussions
sur la fondation des états unis
d'afrique
c'était notre but et c'est ce qu'on
attendait d'eux sarkozy à l'époque
ministre de l'intérieur
l'un des hommes chargés des relations
avec la france est le cousin du
dictateur son stratège son confident
une chose est sûre il nous a montré le
plus grand respect il nous a fait
l'impression d'un homme honnête qui
voulait sincèrement développer nos
relations et corriger les erreurs de la
france en afrique
le dictateur ne peut qu'apprécier ce
ministre qui prône publiquement la
rupture avec le président français du
moment
il s'en retourne en france
avec le pouvoir à conquérir
et s'il ne revient pas en libye
plusieurs de ses proches feront le
voyage
parfois pour parler affaires
car après les années d'embargo l'eau
juste marché libyen suscite des
convoitises
[Musique]
ainsi l'homme d'affaires takieddine
effectué de nombreux séjours dans les
grands hôtels de tripoli
il utilise ses relations dans
l'entourage du futur président pour
importer des contrats d'armement et
vincent ainsi des intermédiaires
implanté de plus longue date
j'ai mes clients eux mêmes qui viennent
vers moi et qui me disent j'ai attaqué
d'eads est arrivé avec un courrier à
en-tête du ministère l'intérieur sarkozy
t'es mise intérieure et dans le courrier
ait marqué je recommande chaudement
monsieur j attaque et dean hommes de
l'industrie très connu par nos services
un homme remarquable pour les
industriels thales dassault snack bar
allons-y pour pourquoi pas mac do
enfin il y en avait pour tous les goûts
et signé monsieur sarkozy
j'ai su après que sarkozy a été
interrogé et à l'elysée
sarkozy va enfin goûter
soyons sérieux j'avais une copie on lui
a répondu ben nous on n'a pas de copine
bon bah alors écoutez enfin vous
connaissez les libanais c'est ce que
j'ai su ce qu'il aurait répandu en effet
les libanais enfin
c'est pas lui qui me mandate un
aliment par contre nicolas sarkozy a
reçu
officiellement
ma désignation
comme interlocuteur de la part des
libyens avec lui
le futur président ne s'est peut-être
pas tout ce qui se trame autour de lui
man son nom mais entre lui le dictateur
il flotte dès lors un fumet affairistes
qui ne serait pas sans conséquence à la
fin de cette histoire
[Musique]
je veux être le président de la france
des droits de l'homme parce que je crois
au plus profond de mon coeur je le veux
pas je ne crois pas ce qu'on appelle la
realpolitik qui fait renoncer à ses
valeurs je le veux être complice tôt
qu'une dictature à travers le monde
[Musique]
en janvier 2007
celui qui exprimait son respect au
dictateur lance sa campagne
présidentielle sur à bien notre ton
[Musique]
gagner une élection vaut bien de se
poser en chantre des droits de l'homme
surtout lorsqu'on est précédée par une
réputation de ministre de l'intérieur à
poigne
c'était l'époque où
une certaine gauche intellectuelle
s'insurge est de ces propos et un moment
donné on a senti chez lui le besoin
aussi de s'adresser à ces intellectuels
là parce que même s'ils ne sont pas
majoritaires dans le pays ils ont une
certaine influence
nicolas sarkozy était sensible très
sensible à ce que pouvait penser les
bernard henri lévy les geeks manly
brenner les droits de l'homme
on ne pouvait pas ne pas me plaire en
plus il est vrai que nicolas sarkozy
avait un langage et dans sa campagne des
thèmes qui étaient très nouveau par
rapport à leur taux d'auxi de la droite
deuxième grand objectif de la france
promouvoir les libertés et les droits de
l'homme sur la scène internationale je
ne me tairais jamais devant ces insultes
aux droits de l'homme bien la france
elle n'est elle-même que quand elle
promeut la liberté contre l'oppression
c'est ainsi qu'à l'issue de la campagne
il recrute deux personnalités atypiques
qui compteront dans la suite de cette
histoire
de bernard kouchner héros de
l'humanitaire il fera son ministre des
affaires étrangères et il invente une
fonction inédite sous la vème république
celle de secrétaire d'état aux droits de
l'homme qu'il confiera à la jeune rama
yade
c'est nicolas sarkozy qui est élu
président de la république avec 53% des
voix résultat salué par une ovation
de ses supporters samedi
salle gaveau un célèbre théâtre parisien
la foule ignore qu'elle va assister aux
premiers actes de la pièce que le nouvel
et lui s'apprête à jouer avec le
dictateur
après les généreuses paroles du candidat
place aux actes du président
là c'est une grosse surprise son
discours de vainqueur salle gaveau à
paris devant ses supporteurs et puis
dans l'euphorie générale
il place le début de son mandat son
terrain de la politique étrangère
c'est en méditerranée que tout va se
jouer
qu'il nous faut surmonter toutes les
haines pour laisser la place à un grand
rêve de paix et un grand rêve de
civilisation
le temps est venu de bâtir une union
méditerranéenne qui sera un trait
d'union entre l'europe et l'afrique ce
qui a été fait pour l'union de l'europe
il ya 60 ans nous allons faire
aujourd'hui pour l'union de la
méditerranée
réunir tous les pays riverains de la
méditerranée au sein d'une union
politique
telle est sa spectaculaire est
surprenant de promesses
tout juste élu et déjà il aspire un coup
de maître qui prouverait à tous qu'il
est ce grand président pareille à nulle
autre qui promettait d'être
pour réussir son pari il a besoin du
soutien d'un état d'afrique du nord
incontournable autant que peu coopératif
dirigé par un peu commode dictateur
le nouveau président a de bonnes raisons
de penser qu'il trouvera en lui un allié
[Musique]
en ce début de quinquennat
tous les chemins le même temps libye
il s'attelle sans tarder à son union
pour la méditerranée
s'efforçant de convaincre les chefs
d'état de la région d'y adhérer
il a aussi en tête les grands contrats
qui pourraient obtenir de la riche libye
lui qui a promis de ramener milliards et
emploie aux entreprises françaises
et puis cerise sur le gâteau il saisit
l'opportunité de réaliser un bon coup de
communication qui contribuerait à sa
gloire
[Musique]
à tripoli en effet
l'imprévisible guide libyen a suscité un
nouvel obstacle dans ses relations avec
l'occident
il détient cinq infirmières bulgares
dans le calvaire émeut l'opinion
internationale
injustement accusées d'avoir inoculé le
virus du sida à des enfants torturés
elles viennent d'être condamnés à mort
et la marque
depuis des mois l'union européenne
négocient leur libération avec le
dictateur
en ce mois de juillet 2007 la
commissaire aux relations extérieures
est sur le point de réussir
dans une journée parce qu'il changeait
toujours tout on a on a négocié ça et
c'était prêt à signer et là nous
voulions signé et tout d'un coup les
libyens il avait coupé tout et il
voulait savoir
oui on n'est pas sûr
nous avons fait le travail on ne savait
pas que sarkozy ait négocié derrière
car à l'elysée dans la plus grande
discrétion
entourée de sa seule gare de rapprocher
jean david levitte son conseiller
diplomatique
henri guaino et l'indispensable claude
guéant le président joue en personne les
négociateurs
on me passe un coup de téléphone le
président sarkozy avait parlé à kadhafi
dis-nous où se trouve kadhafi à deux
heures de l'après midi ou à 5 heures de
l'après midi et c'est comme ça que les
choses se passaient et ça j'ai eu au
moins quatre ou cinq coups de téléphone
pour les sauver bien il fallait aussi
accepter en contrepartie d'abord de
discuter avec des fils a beaucoup joué
ça enfin est-ce que kadhafi se sentaient
considérés
quand vous recevez un coup de téléphone
quand c'est l'oeuvre ce n'est un message
écrit c'est une chose mais qu'ensuite
vous voyez ce no 3 quinze jours après le
nouvel appel et c'est à 3,4 prise sa
marque en tout avec des ces pays là qui
quand même sont des pays où la relation
humaine est fondamentale
pour devenir le libérateur des innocents
d'infirmières le président est prêt à
offrir beaucoup
[Musique]
c'est que le dictateur rêve d'effectuer
une prestigieuse visite officielle en
occident pour marquer son retour sur la
scène internationale
c'est en échange du sauvetage des
infirmières bulgares que qui a été fait
la promesse de recevoir le colonel
kadhafi en visite d'état en visite
d'état à paris
le président accède un autre désir cher
au dictateur
affligé d'avoir dû renoncer à l'armé
nucléaire le libyen veut posséder au
moins une centrale nucléaire symbole de
puissance
depuis des mois ils sollicitent les
autorités françaises jusqu'à présent
circonspecte face aux caprices d'un
dictateur réputé incontrôlable
les gens qui étaient très tout à fait
opposés à s'aventurer ou à s'engager une
aventure assez engagé dans cette voie
même à pas comptés mais là dessus e le
président de la république a arbitré
parce que la chatte reprise h dans les
entretiens
[Musique]
auxquels j'avais auquel j'ai assisté
le président à plusieurs reprises le
président kadhafi c'était ça lui tenait
à coeur ce qu on l a accepté un
personnage extrêmement intelligent très
manoeuvrier un homme de pouvoir très
très efficace il a tiré tout parti qu'il
pouvait tirer de cette négociation et
non pas chercher à obtenir davantage
dans le seul c'est l'accord de défense
qui a fait un tout petit peu un petit
peu de problèmes et parce que les
libyens voulaient une sorte de clause de
défense en disant que en gros si c'est
qu'à attaquer la france de venir à leur
secours on sait bien qu'il n'était pas
question de ça et je sais que mon
homologue
libyen hamadi goethe a pu obtenir à moi
je vous dis donc ça s'excuse un jeu ne
faut pas chercher je vais dire tu ça
passera jamais
le dictateur a obtenu presque tous ceux
qui pouvaient espérer
dans la nuit du 22 juillet 2007 le dit
laissez les
48 heures plus tard au bulgarie un avion
de la république française rend la
liberté aux malheureuses
des dizaines de journalistes sont venus
retransmettre ce succès présidentielle
il découvre alors qu'il comporte un
inattendu volet conjugal
pour aller chercher les infirmières en
libye le président s'est fait représenté
par sa femme cécilia un geste envers le
dictateur et peut-être même plus que
cela
et puis on est des arabes vous savez il
a envoyé sa femme à tripoli ça compte
canon ça nous était difficile de refuser
la demande d'une femme sur un sujet
comme celui là
je crois pour lui c'était important
aussi pour montrer à cécilia que elle
pouvait jouer un grand rôle
si elle restait ça a été un peu ce que
j'ai compris quand elles étaient avec
moi ils espèrent à travers l' affaire
libyenne qu'elle va trouver sa place et
que
comme ça a marché il imagine qu'il va
pouvoir la garder elle a gardé comme ça
avec sa femme le président vit une crise
de couple il cherche à la retenir par
tous les moyens y compris les moins
conventionnel
baroque exercice du pouvoir
ou diplomatie et vie privée semaine
[Applaudissements]
alors mesdames et messieurs je vous
remercie d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation
dans des délais aussi brefs je voulais
vous dire quel était notre joie
devant la fin de ce long calvaire
qui a frappé cinq femmes puis vous
comprendrez que je dise également que
ces six lits a fait un travail tout à
fait remarquable
que pour est une phrase courte et n'en
est pas moins très sincère deux mois
seulement après son arrivée au pouvoir
le dictateur lui offre cette victoire
diplomatique éclatante de surcroît par
et de bons sentiments de toutes sortes
et ce ne sont pas les interrogations de
la presse qui vont gâcher ce moment on
sait bien que rien ne se fait avec
colonel kadhafi sans compensation bois
plus où poser la question la france
at-elle verser 1 euro ma réponse c'est
non
de quoi s'agissait-il il s'agissait
d'arracher cinq malheureuses femmes un
sort bien peu enviable il y avait un
problème à résoudre on l'a résolu points
natama d'alma
pour servir nos intérêts dans notre
projet africain nous avions décidé de
soutenir nicolas sarkozy dans cette
affaire par tous les moyens
en l'occurrence nous voulions lui donner
une carte à jouer
cette carte le président va venir la
jouer en libye dès le lendemain
[Musique]
deux ans après son premier séjour le
président est de retour à tripoli
l'ambassadeur méritants et le chef du
protocole libyen l'attendent au bas du
tapis rouge
[Musique]
il est accueilli en grande pompe et en
terrain connu
la libération des infirmières et pour le
président des droits de l'homme un
paravent commode
qui s'offusqueraient en effet de cette
escale à tripoli au lendemain d'une si
émouvante libération
il peut passer en toute quiétude aux
choses sérieuses avec le dictateur
[Musique]
autant la première visite avait été un
peu fade discrète depuis papa lé là ça a
été la fiesta voilà
dans le jardin de sa caserne au pied
d'un bâtiment laissé en l'état depuis le
bombardement américain de 1986
c'est un dictateur en tenue d'apparat
qui accueille le président et son
importante délégation
parmi elles se trouve la jeune
secrétaire d'état aux droits de l'homme
rama yade
arrivé à moi il me serre la main et je
lui serre la main et
il me il était d'ailleurs étrange on
n'aurait pas dit un président parce que
tu es habillée tout mon costume blanc
avec sur la poitrine une carte de
l'afrique en plastique où il est noir et
puis des lunettes de soleil puis ses
cheveux tout l'envié où vit le jeu c'est
pas trop et et puis donc il se pensait
le représentant de l'afrique mans étant
d'origine africaine donc il a dû penser
qu'on devait avoir une complicité
particulière et donc il me dit mais
comment à 30 ans vous êtes ministre
et moi tac au tac que j'ose y répondez
vous à 27 ans vous aviez bien faire un
coup d'état et là je vois le regard du
président sarkozy qui part dans tous les
sens et puis lui ça le fait rire
manifestement
[Musique]
[Rires]
l'heure est à l'idylle
surtout lorsque vient la signature d'une
dizaine d'accords de coopération
les chefs
auparavant c'est moi qui avait été
chargé de rédiger ces accords
le guide m'a dit textuellement aura
s'agissant de la france il ne faut pas
t'inquiéter
sarkozy est notre ami tout va bien pour
nos essais détenant au moins atteint
même
l'accord sur la défense en particulier a
de quoi réjouir le dictateur la france
entraînera ses forces spéciales et lui
fournira les armes les plus modernes
à la suite de ce rapprochement les
français lui vendre ont même un système
de surveillance d'internet qui
l'utilisera pour traquer ses opposants
ceci il est vrai test à l'époque fort
peu dans la balance
quand vous faites des contrats de vente
d'armes vous imaginez bien que le
gouvernement peut effectivement
d utiliser d'une autre manière que pour
préserver l'indépendance dépendance
nationale
voilà mais faut-il donc une plus vendre
d'armes quiconque vous trouverez
toujours quelqu'un pour leur vendre des
armes et
ouais là encore c'est la difficulté
difficulté morale de
de tout cela mais
le monde et comme idée
pour le président ces accords sont de
moindre importance à côté du dossier
qu'il a prévu d'évoquer dans quelques
minutes avec le dictateur
sa chère union pour la méditerranée
après deux mois de présidence elle
semble à portée de main
il a besoin toutefois du soutien
déterminant de son être
un axe majeur de sa politique étrangère
oui arrivé avec un esprit cartésien été
une discussion structuré en tête en face
l'interlocuteur n'était pas dans les
mêmes dispositions
intellectualisme j'ai le souvenir d'une
scène de théâtre
d'une
incommunication flagrante d'une comédie
jouée par
mouammar kadhafi
avec tout l'enthousiasmé dont il est
capable le président expose sa vision
géopolitique au maître des lieux à qui
il offre de leurs alliés
il répondait pas où il disait j'ai trois
quatre mots en arabe sans rapport du
tout avec la discussion qu'on voulait
avoir avec lui il y avait des éclairages
sur ce qu'on pouvait lui vendre
en général ce type c'est pourquoi des
armes antichars pourquoi
nous ne savions pas fallait comprendre
des conseils
le dictateur élude
bernard kouchner recentre la discussion
avec un peu d'insistance
[Musique]
le président l'a repris en disant
pratiquement en disant as kadhafi
n'écoutez pas ce que dit mon ministre
des affaires étrangères dans sa cause il
voulait une visite qui se passe bien bon
tu sais je suis là pour faire plaisir à
mon hôte qui m'a fait donc autant ne pas
lui compliquer de ne pas évoquer le show
dans le détail nous rend gros le
président a dit on verra on vous
précisera les choses les grandes lignes
tout ça
lorsqu'il quitte la tente le président
ne doute pas de gagner son hôte à sa
cause
[Musique]
le dictateur lui masquer sa déception
il escomptait un président à qui a ses
rêves africain
il reçoit un ambitieux qui lui demande
de se rallier à un projet concurrent
[Musique]
nous nous pensions que sarkozy avait
pris en compte le projet que nous avions
impulsé en afrique et là nous constatons
qu'il cherche juste à se donner un rôle
historique qu'il veut être le chef
kadhafi a toujours eu cette ambition un
peu fantasque mais enfin de
rassembler
l'afrique ou en tout cas une partie de
l'afrique et il a essayé d'atteindre cet
objectif plus par l'ingérence que par la
coopération donc notre message assez
évident été de lui dire puisque vous
avez renoncé au terrorisme et aux armes
de destruction massive renoncé aussi à
l'ingérence à la déstabilisation de vos
voisins
trop sûr de lui le président mais
estiment les ambitions du roi des rois
d'afrique
[Musique]
bref l'entrevue se révèle un jeu de
dupes chacun se méprenant sur les
intentions de l'autre
dans la soirée nicolas sarkozy on
retrouve à l'hôtel où là il va faire un
long il va débriefer longuement son
entrevue avec kadhafi il est très
contente de cette affaire il ne cesse de
la raconter tenter plus est très content
de son début de mandat qu'il veut
absolument marquer à un gros coup sur le
plan sur le plan diplomatique
c'est ce qu'ils cherchent son grand
dessein c'est de réunir tout le monde il
ajoute qu'à david ans dans son puzzle
mois les échos que j'en ai vu c'est
quelque chose s'était bien passé le
colonel kadhafi s'étaient montrés très
ouverts sur l'idée du million pour la mi
année
[Musique]
de retour vers la france il reste à
l'hyperprésident comment commence à le
surnommer à honorer une promesse
la visite officielle qu'il a offerte aux
dictateurs
[Musique]
il compte bien qu'elle renforce son
entente avec lui et parachève sa grande
offensive diplomatique de début de
mandat
[Musique]
cinq mois plus tard en décembre
la femme du président est finalement
parti
le dictateur arrive
la veille de sa venue les deux hommes se
croisent à lisbonne dans le cadre d'un
sommet international
mais le président va recevoir un
dictateur resté fidèle à lui même
il vient de faire scandale en déclarant
à un journal portugais
raphaël
[Musique]
permettez moi de dire qu'il ya moins de
problèmes à recevoir le président
kadhafi dont les services collaborent
avec les services occidentaux dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme quand les
infirmières ont été libérés dans un
avion de la république française pour le
reste il a sa personnalité
son tempérament
c'est pas moi qui vais les juges et
[Musique]
au petit matin ce lundi
en déroule le tapis rouge
par rouleau entier
dans la cour d'honneur de l'elysée et en
face dans les jardins d'une annexe du
palais
première dans les annales du protocole
on y adresser une vaste tente bédouine
koulouba par le plein
ils ont accepté toutes nos demandes
le message de kadhafi pour sa première
visite en occident après une longue
période de rupture c'était ce n'est même
pas parce que je me rends en europe que
je change
mais voilà qu'un grain de sable vient
gripper le bel ordonnancement
personne à l'elysée ne s'est aperçu que
le dictateur arrive à une date un peu
particulière
la journée internationale des droits de
l'homme
or le président a justement nommée une
secrétaire d'état chargée de ce sujet là
avant cela
j'ai rencontré les infirmières bulgares
que je n'avais jamais rencontré depuis
et il sut sortie de cette rencontre
bouleversée parce qu'elles m'ont raconté
les conditions de leur détention avec
les attaques des chiens enfin des choses
absolument cauchemardesque pour ne vous
ne lisez même pas dans la presse et ça a
modifié évidemment mon regard
j'ai essayé de demander le changement de
date parce que le 10 décembre était
symbolique y'avait pas d'argumentaire
c'est comme ça passe comme ça et puis
c'est décider si tu allais je n'avais
pas à me mêler de la domaine réservé du
président
alors à l'heure du laitier ce lundi
matin la jeune secrétaire d'état frappe
un grand coup
à un journal elle lance la france n'est
pas un paillasson sur lequel un
dirigeant peut venir s'essuyer les pieds
de ses forfaits avant de rééditer à la
radio
avec une journée le droit de l'homme sur
les bras et kanak et le tarmac d'orly
donc pour moi il est un problème
au retour de la radio vers 9h 9h30 le
présent à pic m'appelle en me disant de
venir le voir à l'elysée
et il était silencieux nous tournons le
dos face à la fenêtre est le silence
dure très longtemps
puis arrivent les deux conseillers
d'aller vite messieurs l'éviter guéant
qui donc me sermonne lourdement vous
rendez compte si son avion est dans le
ciel français ne veut pas atterrir bon
je suis dit écoute et qu'il rentre chez
lui bon après il me dit c'est pas le
moment de présenter donc j'ai raté de
présenter et jude effectivement c'est
très sérieux et nicolas sarkozy les
arrête et puis leur demande de me
de préparer la suite avec moi savoir
qu'est ce que je dis ma faim bon ils
m'ont envoyé sur europe 1
je suis de tourner autour du pot la
rebelle et contraintes d'approuver du
bout des lèvres cette visite qui
commence décidément sous de mauvais
auspices
[Musique]
et enfin d'une matinée pluvieuse le
dictateur fini par débarquer à orly à la
tête de ces amazones
et d'une suite de 200 personnes
l'ancien parrain du terrorisme s'offrent
pour la première fois une visite
prestigieuse dans une grande capitale
occidentale
qui plus est celle d'un pays qu'il a
longtemps combattu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
se trouvait là est pour lui un succès
éclatant
il ne s'en cache pas
le programme conduit à concocter n'en
est-il pas la preuve
d'abord cette réception ici même
puis à l'assemblée nationale
enfin ce dîner de gala en son honneur
au caire
nous avons beaucoup apprécié qu'on ne
servent du couscous à l'elysée
c'était un message tout à fait positive
il était très heureux de tout ce que le
gouvernement français lui offrait
il a été accueilli avec grande
différence
autant alors faire durer le plaisir
en france l'usagé diplomatique veut que
les visites officielles dure trois jours
le dictateur demande à prolonger son
séjour de trois de plus une semaine en
tout
je dis pas qui s'est invitée mais il a
demandé à rester à paris on lui a
accordé bien évidemment puisqu'on succès
ont souhaité que cette visite soit lui
soit agréable à chaque jour il inventait
un nouveau sujet de préoccupation quand
il y bien vous disent écoutez je vais
petit je souhaite aller à versailles
parce que j'ai toujours rêvé difficile
de lire annonce n'est pas allée
versailles non non c'est trop pour vous
[Musique]
le touriste de marque fait privatiser le
célèbre château royal
avant de filer au louvre
puis de réclamer d'autres
divertissements encore à des
organisateurs quelque peu dépassé
il avait décidé de visiter paris en
bateau-mouche pas vous imaginer ce que
ça représente en terme de sécurité
puisque il faut sécuriser les berges
mais aussi des ponts et pourquoi ne pas
lui dire non tout simplement difficile
de refuser à une personnalité qu'on
reçoit le droit de découvrir paris en
bateau mouche
[Musique]
partis à la chasse à rambouillet des
chasseurs moi même puisque avec un seul
fusil c'était celui ce cas la fille mais
les services de sécurité était en place
depuis 9 heures du matin pour bloquer
mais pour bloquer au moment du passage
du convoi convoi est arrivé vers 12h30
une heure
les rues bloquées exaspère les parisiens
la pompe déployés pour un dictateur choc
les français
il assiste à des scènes comme celle là
de pacifique d'opposants en exil
séquestré dans un quart d heure durant
afin d'éviter que le dirigeant libyen ne
les aperçoit sur son passage
les plus sidéré sont les proches des 170
victimes de l'attentât commis sur ordre
du dictateur contre un avion français en
[Musique]
ce jeune homme il ya perdu son père
n'oublie pas
j'imaginais dans dix ans le président
américain qui reçoit ben laden à la
maison de lancer que j'ai fait signer
des contrats
quatre ans auparavant
le dictateur a consenti à indemniser les
familles des victimes du dc 10 d'uta
mais il refuse toujours d'extrader les
auteurs de l'attentât
parmi lesquels son propre bras droit
avant sa venue à paris les familles
avaient demandé à être reçus par le
président un de ses collaborateurs les
avaient été conduits
bio c'est pas grave on ne fait pas
d'omelette sans casser des oeufs en pas
s'embêter si elle est un peu de
poussière dans les coins je suis assez
choqué par cette façon de voir les
choses ce à quoi il est dit mais tous on
pourra pas vous recevoir ça n'est pas
question ça ferait un incident
diplomatique
on est resté là dessus
mais au cours de la visite le président
est contraint de faire volte-face devant
les caméras pour donner un gage à
l'opinion on par crainte d'un scandale
[Applaudissements]
je crois qu'il était un peu angoissée
des de nous voir d'où le fait qu'il
était dans un monologue
il disait que ben qu'il y avait beaucoup
de fatwa contre lui qu'il était victime
lui-même en disant qu'il était visé par
le terrorisme il a voulu créer une
empathie avec nous sauf comment la liste
est pas le bon canal
il voulait montrer que lui-même était
une victime
[Musique]
résumons le président invite le
dictateur pour sauver des victimes
bulgares
refuse de recevoir d'autres victimes
françaises du terrorisme libyen les
reçoit finalement et se pose lui-même en
victime
le coût diplomatique vire à la farce et
à la crise médiatico politique
une visite qui dérange des voix qui
s'élèvent c'est la question du jour le
président les biens est il oui ou non le
bienvenu c'est une erreur et c'est même
incompréhensible que la sarkozie dit
qu'il a changé puisqu'il faut la faire
des infirmières bulgares quand on prend
cinq otages qu on les torture qu'on
l'ait martyrise pendant des années et
qu'on les rencontre rançon ça s'appelle
comment
face à la multiplication des critiques
le susceptible dictateur riposte en
organisant à l'unesco un meeting à sa
gloire
[Musique]
nous avions prévenu personne de cette
initiative et je peux vous dire que les
français qui organisait la visite ont
été très vexé par le discours de frère
mouammar
cette visite tourne à la farce tragi
comique que des relations diplomatiques
normales soit établi avec la libye cela
se conçoit mais que la france fasse le
cadeau d'une réhabilitation à grands
frais c'est une maladresse qui nous
coûtera monsieur le ministre des
affaires étrangères bernard kouchner
jusqu'où irez-vous dans la négation de
vous même où la parole est à monsieur le
ministre
jusqu'à présent le chef de la diplomatie
caution humanitaire du président s'était
prudemment tenu à l'écart de la visite
controversée cité un certain nombre des
prises de position de monsieur kadhafi
sachez que je les réprouve lorsqu'il a
parlé des droits de l'homme ici c'est à
dire des droits de l'homme dans notre
pays en europe c'était assez pitoyable
jeudi c'est pitoyable oui c'est
pitoyable mais je vois là c'est ce que
je pense mais je n'avais pas changé
lorsque les colas sarkozy m'a proposé
d'être ministre des affaires étrangères
et savaient très bien qu'ils demandaient
je sentais bien que tout ça l'agacé bien
sûr
de l'autre côté de la rue pour le
dictateur c'en est trop il attendait que
cette visite consacre sa respectabilité
au lieu de cela on l'a jury on le juge
qui toi yable ils soupçonnent le
président lui même de le trahir
car enfin un ministre peut-il agir sans
l'accord de son chef devant ses
conseillers il entre dans une colère
terrible
kadhafi a été trompé par sarkozy
avait lui été clair comme de l'eau de
roche et sarkozy s'est comporté avec
four but rennais
c'était une attitude contraire à toute
diplomatie riyad doublement assez pour
nous musulmans et diplomates c'était un
comportement inadmissible
si le détestaient pourquoi j'invite est
il en france q est-il chaleureusement
pourquoi était-il venu le visiter en
libye
tout ça c'était de l'hypocrisie
la situation s'envenime encore lorsque
le président tente désespérément de
désamorcer la polémique qui agite la
france
c'est bien drôle et nos sons droits de
l'homme et les postures entre le café
flore et les ennemis
mais ses postures elles ont laissé
pendant huit ans et malheureuse affirmé
m j'ai dit au président kadhafi
combien il fallait continuer à
progresser sur le chemin des droits de
l'homme
dans tous ses aspects tout ce qu'il
reste à faire
[Musique]
maintenant ce président lui fait
publiquement la leçon
la coupe est pleine
[Musique]
la vengeance est un plat qui se mange
froid aussi le dictateur ne laisse rien
paraître de son courroux lorsqu'il va
retrouver son hôte
le dernier entretien qui s'est fait
sarkozy a tenu à le concevoir j'ai pu
très bien mais en tout cas
c'est président sarkozy qui lui a dit je
suis désolée si la presse de la maladie
etc etc à la fille très grand seigneur
il a répondu écoutez ça vous n'y est
absolument pour rien freddy livrer ses
livres dans votre pays gagner c'est
votre problème la presse français c'est
pas mon problème moi je verrai avec la
mienne en amont retour mais j'ai eu
aucun souci là même du représentant j'ai
aucun souci avec ma presse
justement la presse française à laquelle
il a promis une interview va être
l'instrument de sa vengeance
[Applaudissements]
ça tourne pour tout le monde ça marche
ok alors on y va
3 2 1 alors cette visite en france
provoquent ici un vif débat et le
boycott de certains élus comment
réagissez vous à cette controverse
le président nicolas sarkozy a indiqué
hier qu'il vous avait demandé de
progresser sur le chemin des droits de
l'homme la
cause
vous pouvez remercier encore
le jour
le missile est envoyée
la presse fait des gorges chaudes de ce
cinglant démenti du dictateur
sauterel merci beaucoup
[Musique]
mortifié
publiquement humilié
le président tente de faire bonne figure
en sortant son joker
je vais signer une dizaine de milliards
de contrats avec la partie libyenne
c'est pour l'emploi la croissance des
français
et que les choses soient claires je suis
là aussi pour me battre aux côtés des
entreprises et des usines françaises
pour que nous ayons les contrats et les
commandes que les autres étaient
tellement contents d'avoir à notre place
sans rien renoncé de mes convictions en
matière de droits de l'homme
alors le président convient la presse à
une édifiante cérémonie
quand elle porte sur l'achat de 15
appareils donc sept a320 quatre a330 et
4 a350
rafale hélicoptères avions de ligne la
liste est impressionnante
pourtant les deux hommes ne s'accordent
pas un regard
le dictateur ravale sa colère
à ce président indigne de confiance
il va faire payer une addition à sa
manière
infirmière contre visite à paris il
s'estime kit
kadhafi mentait et tous les contrats
ensuite qui ont été signés ou proposer à
paris il y en a aucun qui a été suivie
d'effet voilà c'était un fiasco
tout était compliqué on prend des
engagements on est des faits on est rené
goscinny ont fait ont fait traîner on
aurait vendu beaucoup de rafale ainsi de
toutes les promesses et tous les pré
contrats signés pour des engagements
s'ils n'y avaient été tenus d affaires
ne peuvent pas se faire sans qu'il y ait
une politique extérieure corinthe et
assurant tu sais ça quand je vous dis
des amateurs
ironie de l'histoire
la france aura après la visite - de
parts de marché en libye qu'à l'arrivée
au pouvoir du président
même la centrale nucléaire ne se vend
pas
l'industriel areva s'y opposent jugeant
insensé cette volonté présidentielle
[Musique]
l'année suivante en juillet 2008 le
président accueille à paris le sommet
fondateur de son union pour la
méditerranée devant une quarantaine de
chefs d'état
mesdames et messieurs
avec le président moubarak
nous déclarons ouvert
le sommet fondateur de l'union pour la
méditerranée le seul qui
fidèle à sa son imprévisibilité a décidé
de déclarer forfait
c'est finalement kadhafi et non
seulement il a déclaré forfait mais il a
boudé en disant c'est pas comme ça qu'il
fallait le faire malik d'affilée ce qui
a mené kadhafi à la rupture avec sarkozy
c'est la quête de leadership de sarkozy
vaut kadhafi les pays africains sont au
nombre de 54 ils sont plus nombreux que
les pays européens
préférant rester maître sur son
continent le dictateur multiplie les
déclarations hostiles à l'union pour la
méditerranée
fragilisé dès ses débuts par l'absence
de la libye cette union ne verra jamais
le jour
[Applaudissements]
l' aventure libyenne et pour le
président un échec cuisant
elle a mis en lumière ces défauts son
exercice solitaire du pouvoir un certain
amateurisme
cela explique sans doute qu'elles
coïncident dans les sondages avec le
début d'une impopularité durable
[Musique]
dans les trois années suivantes le
président ne veut plus entendre parler
du dictateur
jusqu'à un certain jour de février 2011
[Musique]
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé au
moyen-orient une chose est
extraordinaire
c'est que les peuples arabes ont décidé
sans violence de prendre leur destin en
main ces peuples aspirent à la
démocratie et au progrès social alors
que jusqu'à présent on avait plutôt
des régimes
autoritaires
dont nous avions des rapports avec eux
parce qu'ils étaient laïques et parce
qu'il n'y avait pas d'autre solution
d'alternative crédible aujourd'hui à
cette alternative il se trouve en
turquie lorsqu'il réagit à une
stupéfiante nouvelle
début 2011 des révolutions ont balayé
demanderez minant de son upm l'égyptien
moubarak et le tunisien ben ali
et voici que les libyens à leur tour se
soulève contre leurs dictateurs
lui n'hésite pas à faire mitrailler la
foule de ses opposants
[Applaudissements]
notre position est claire monsieur
kadhafi doit partir
[Musique]
comme tous les dirigeants occidentaux le
président s'empresse de condamner le
désormais indéfendable guide libyen
ces mots ont bien peu de poids
alors que les printemps arabes ont la
sympathie de l'opinion le souvenir de sa
lune de miel avec le dictateur sanglant
est devenu gênant
ce bilan diplomatique ternie tombe au
plus mal car dans un an il remettra en
jeu son mandat
et si au contraire li tirer avantage de
la situation pour se représidentialiser
c'est ce que lui suggère de faire un de
ses conseillers
la situation internationale nous permet
de tenter une opération politique dictée
par les événements le message de
dimanche soir est extrêmement important
c'est de là que peut s'amorcer la
reconquête
mes chers compatriotes
c'est mon devoir de prendre les
décisions qui s'imposent quand les
circonstances l'exigent nous avons donc
le devoir d'agir face à la crise
libyenne dont les conséquences
pourraient être très lourdes pour la
stabilité de toute la région le
président la république
lui a été mobilisée tout de suite a très
bien compris que cette affaire allait
tourner à la tragédie
avec des dimensions effroyable
et le souvenir que je garde c'est qu'il
m'avait demandé à l'époque
comment s'était déroulée
la sphère de srebrenica puisque j'étais
auprès du président chirac à l'époque
calculé conviction sans doute se mêlent
début mars le président fait planifier
une action militaire
seul ou presque parmi les dirigeants
occidentaux
car nul ne sait comment intervenir dans
une situation de plus en plus chaotique
par qui remplacer le dictateur
et voilà que le 5 mars le président
reçoit l'appel providentielle d'un
donneur de leçons du café de flore qu il
vitupérait en 2007
bernard henri lévy le philosophe
médiatique se trouve à benghazi fief de
l'insurrection auprès des chefs des
rebelles
[Musique]
j'ai appelé tout bêtement le standard de
l'elysée que par miracle j'avais sur un
sur
un agenda électronique avec moi
président de la république nicolas
sarkozy au bout du fil je lui ai dit je
suis avec les nouveaux dirigeants du
conseil national de transition qui vient
de se créer
accepteriez-vous et puis accepterais-tu
on est vite repassé au tutoiement
d'autrefois de les recevoir il n'a
répondu oui naturellement question mais
quand le plus vite possible qu'il vienne
[Musique]
à
commencer par nous parler de la visite
de kadhafi à paris
il nous a dit kadhafi était le président
d'un pays il fallait le recevoir je les
ai reçus vous comprenez
je n'étais pas sûr de lui faire
confiance à cause du passé mais bon je
n'avais pas le choix maintenant que le
peuple libyen a fait un autre choix je
suis prêt à vous aider et puis sarkozy
nous a dit qu'il reconnaissait le cnt
comme unique représentant du peuple
libyen
il ne croyait tellement pas tout ça
naturellement je suppose doit être
secret et sarkozy feint de réfléchir
regarde les vite gars
secret ou et je ne sais pas non
un coup de théâtre
le président saute sur l'occasion de
reconnaître ses opposants comme le seul
pouvoir légitime de libye
sa décision revient tout bonnement a
destitué le dictateur honni
cela vaut bien de prendre quelques
risques
en effet nul ne connaît la capacité de
ce cnt conseil national de transition à
gouverner demain nul ne sait quel point
peste au juste les islamistes
[Applaudissements]
les français se mettent en avant une
façon spectaculaire qui heurte
profondément et qui n'est pas comprise
qui n'est pas comprise ni par les
britanniques nono qui vont devenir nos
élites qui sont sidérés je ne parle même
pas du fait des autres partenaires
européens les allemands sont merkel est
furieuse les américains sont encore plus
sidéré d'ailleurs les américains pendant
très longtemps vont selon continuent de
poser la question qui sont ces gens qui
sont ces gens et et disposant évidemment
d'informations précises sur le passé de
certains est très très inquiet à
washington de la composante islamiste du
risque de dérapage de ce qu'il
adviendrait tout cela bien sûr cet été
au risque
même temps tellement une menace sur
l'avenir enfin on avait le choix entre
soutenir le conseil national de
transition et c'est ce qui l'entouré
forcément dans ce qui l'entouré
puisqu'il y avait les forces hostiles au
régime il y avait aussi des forces plus
ou moins menaçante
mais
c'était ça ou kadhafi
à côté
[Musique]
il a été stupéfait que sarkozy s'ingère
dans ce conflit
ils n'ont même pas cherché à dialoguer
aucun émissaire français n'est venu sur
place en libye
semble qu'il y avait déjà un plan pour
se débarrasser de kadhafi
le trafic
[Applaudissements]
fou de rage le dictateur comme l erreur
d'envoyer ses chars contre la ville
rebelle de benghazi
[Musique]
sans le savoir ils donnent un coup de
pouce décisif au président qui en moins
de 10 jours parvient à réunir une
coalition internationale et à obtenir
une résolution de l'onu
le 19 mars à l'instant même où ses
alliés se réunissent à l'elysée le
président leur apprend que deux rafale
viennent de tirer leurs premiers
missiles sur les troupes du dictateur
[Musique]
c'est le début de huit mois de guerre
j'ai un souvenir assez précis - titre
personnel puisque nicolas sarkozy me
reçoit juste après le la décision
d'envoyer l'aviation au dessus de
benghazi je crois qu hillary clinton
elle parle d'une guerre obsessionnel la
guerre de sarkozy je crois qu'elle dit
même elle emploie ce mot là et c'est
vrai qu'il ya ce côté là il y côtoie
habité par sa il fait installer une
carte dans son bureau il a la carte de
la libye la connais par coeur il a un
point précis en permanence par son chef
d'état major lui intervenait commente l
écart est en effet président sarkozy
trouve elle toujours des petits points
de progrès puisque les couleurs étaient
différentes icônes effet absolument
parker ça que petits villages tenus par
les uns ou par les autres
retranché dans sa capitale le dictateur
résiste mieux que prévu à la guerre du
président
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de son arsenal il dégaine même l'armée
nouvelle
[Musique]
17h00 elle est interdite et nous aussi
de falla
contre la fille disait la pure vérité il
a dit ce qu'il avait à dire et c'est
tout c'est plutôt un reproche il ne
pensait pas dévoiler un grand secret à
ce moment là on t'a aidé arrivée à
l'elysée et toi tu fais une chose
pareille c'est un peu comme si l'air
dans son coeur avait accusé la chine
d'avoir
utilisé l'argent des nazis pour financer
ses campagnes électorales enfin enfin
s'imaginer que je crois qu'il n'a jamais
imaginé qu'on puisse donner le moindre
crédit
à ce genre de paroles
couverte par le bruit des bombes
l'accusation n'est pas étayée par le
dictateur mais elle finira par un surgir
au large de tripoli le président lui
vient encourager ses troupes
débuté six mois plus tôt le conflit
s'enlise la rébellion piétine le chef
des armées s'est intensifié les
opérations est parachuté des tonnes
d'armes aux opposants libyens
autant autour de lui il ya eu parfois du
flottement un chat démons du
gouvernement tous n'étaient pas
convaincus à paris dans la nécessité
d'agir en libye mais lui
jusqu'au bout les échanges qu'il a avec
des gens qui le fréquentent à ce moment
là c'est je vais le mettre à genoux il a
mordu la poussière mais je bouge pas
entendu suppression de ce genre mais
c'est pas impossible je ne sais pas
impossible parce que des deux côtés ton
évidemment le temps le ton monte ça
devient spécialité de défi presque
presque personne il faut qu'il y en ait
un qui perdent qui perdent tout
celui qui perd tout c'est bien sûr le
dictateur
[Applaudissements]
à la fin de l'été 2011 sont allés tombe
aux mains de ses ennemis
deux mois plus tard son convoi est
attaqué par des avions français
lui même est capturé par des rebelles
[Applaudissements]
cinq ans
l'objectif
c'est que la libye retrouve sa liberté
et un espoir démocratique
on ne doit jamais se réjouir de la mort
d'un homme quel que soit ce qui les fait
et la menace que faisait peser kadhafi
est une menace réelle sur l'avenir de
l'est
depuis
[Musique]
septembre 2011
lorsqu'ils foulent le sol libyen pour la
troisième fois de sa vie il est un
présidente débarrasser de son dictateur
[Musique]
il faut que tous les dictateurs du monde
comprenne que dans le monde du 21e
siècle il n'y aura pas un endroit où ils
pourront s'assurer de leur impunité
l'impunité c'est fini je vous remercie
dans l'euphorie de sa victoire
il a presque les mêmes mots que pendant
sa campagne de 2007
[Musique]
comme si de cette manière ils voulaient
effacer les cinq années de sa relation
avec le dictateur
comme si à quelques mois d'une autre
campagne électorale il venait conclure
ici cette peu glorieuse histoire
pourtant alors qu'il repart en libye la
suite de l'histoire s'écrit déjà
l'opposition qui l'a soutenu et choix
gouverner une guerre civile éclate
le pays imposent
les islamistes s'implante la région en
proie au chaos
[Applaudissements]
en provoquant la chute du dictateur
il a évité un massacre
mais créer un monstre
le suivi c'est à dire l'après guerre
n'a pas été suffisant je crois qu'il
aurait été
souhaitable d'être plus présents pour
les aider à construire ce n'était pas
leur choix mais sera dû être notre
devoir si on devait avoir un regret la
exprimer mais j'ajoute que cette période
là a coïncidé avec nos élections
l'arrivée d'un nouveau président de la
république et donc par la force des
choses ou du calendrier démocratique
français nous nous sommes trouvés dans
une période de transition
[Musique]
la faute donc à des élections françaises
que sa guerre en libye n'aura pas permis
de remporter
l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là
après son départ de l'elysée continue de
planer au dessus de sa tête comme une
malédiction
à moins que ce ne soit la morale de
cette fable
à la suite du dictateur des affairistes
déçu et d'anciens caciques du régime
l'accusent d'avoir reçu de l'argent
libyen pour sa campagne de 2007
soupçon infamant qui perd ni ses
ambitions futures
sept-îles compromis
ou bien président d'une démocratie
paie-t-il tout simplement le fait de
s'être aventuré avec un tel dictateur
[Musique]
le colonel kadhafi aurait financer votre
campagne en 2007 est ce que c'est